这两天吃床发了
这个顺庄
这个才是做自媒体
开我的样子
今天和大家分享的
一条纯纯的感觉
就是到底该怎么做自媒体
一些有那些军体识操的
方法
你肯定会有一道理我问题
就是你准备的好几号
结果拍完以后呢
根本就没人看
对吧
这就多一点了
为什么
各位好好体会的优号
自媒体
不是输出
而是制造对话
你好好体会理一下
那个内容他是火材
但是对话
才是火
给大家分享一个非常具体的案例
你像
我呢就平时就是哪个
哪个大脸对我刚来是有这样
有些说直播的时候
就上来又说还有一肥化
就是就是哪个脸对象就
就和大家老客流条
第一的时候的你就是2000
再见
我最高的时候一万多
都是同时在建议人数
可是我一旦放弹一些
放弹一些切件
然后这个内容是非常非常干的
流量马上就下来
我前两个有
我算是放弹了
服误的从事
就上台
那时候那个如果是花了
六期三大样
好拍拍摄
大家可以看那个小伙有人看过那种视频吗
那个是干活存存的干活三个小时
那种我都是体现准备好的
然后很认真地去准备
然后去沟通
但是那条视频的
播放量是非常非常差的
然后我还在这想
为什么一条有用的那种
别人不愿意看呢
我算是画了好长时间
我去研究它你们能想到是什么原因吗
我后来用了一个小方法
马上不放量就下了就上去了
大家找了怎么做的吗
就是我在
剪切削短视频之前
我记乎什么的没办法就是剪切短视频之前
我加了一段
独白
就提上一个那样说
我前两天放弹了谁谁
然后呢
为什么要放弹弹
然后这段视频我给大家准备提供什么
然后流量一些上来
可以为什么呢
因为我在放弹
上那时候我们俩是主缺
大家在看我们俩这个时候的内容是传播
但是我一上来拍一条堆不白我就和大量聊了
我说我之前俩拍了
放弹了上弹了
然后我就想到什么注意这个时候我是在盒里堆花
然后我和上那房移成为了我们这次对话的
素材
所以各位思考也就我们上学的时候
一个老师讲在好
还你听了是不是想睡觉睡觉
就这样睡着了对不对
但是如果老实在盒里堆花了在盒里
郭通在盒里提问
这个时候你的脑袭包就会为几乎
然后我们的对话会成为这次刻堂内容的一部分
所以各位
好好体会的句话
自没提本身不是
传播
而是制造对话
我们
这个内容是什么呢是直选
但是对话
糊粉
我打算大家就就提回来了
有请大家可以看一下马斯科
他在推特里边
随便发条件
这么留言呢
他说
Ni会去带人内吗
我一下下面试试一条评论
我在刚来
短片明台之前
来的时候呢有一个诸名的创听教练
一个朋友
我来的时候他30万分次
我30万分次的时候他30万分次
我30万分次的时候他还是30万分次
还还掉了几个份
后来呢
我们在机场见面了他就问我说你这个
四媒体怎么怎么
长得这么快
为什么我就只不不起来了
我说因为你是老师
我是哥们
所以人们都愿意和哥们够通
旁边明白他说他具体怎么做那种很简单
我会恢复大家的留言
所以各位体会一些最有话
你的评论区是你内容的
第2现场
给大家介绍一些非常实际潮的方法
到底该怎么做
首先第1个在你拍特短视频之前
你就必须有
我在和大家溝通聊天的
这样一个心态
我刚来
短视频之前啊你们知道吗刚拍的时候我之前的时候
我说话都是专业时候你又今天会给一些打垃圾的做自行吗
然后呢
说的都是专业数比较重要的会加一些英文
你们有着看电视能看的这种人
但是我做短视频平平台
这就不行了
所以那个时候早期我做短视频平台之前你们知道我通常会有个动作
我会喝点披油
然后把手盘起来你们认真看啊我早期的很多视频一开始都是盘扫做的
然后
为什么就是通过这些外部的动作让我进入用状态就是我在和大家
聊天我在和大家溝通在吹牛在车旦
而不是去讲课而不是去回报
一直以到今天我其实不需要任何的付注我就可以直接进入微选的状态
所以好的经常看我你今天有喝多少就没有
不需要了
因为我每次拍视频之前一定会把自己经过的那个状态
我要和老火几门聊天了
所以有些时候越不正式越好
甚至有些时候偶尔说说两句话
反而是好事
第一个就是你在心态上这样
第二个话呢你在做短视频的时候
你一定要想办法
就有那种场景感
把人拉到你的对话里来比如说你经常聊聊你会说
你没有没有那种情况
你没遇遇到过这样的问题
这个问题你们是怎么想的
这个很重要的
主要不是刻意的做
而是你就是前面第一条
你脑子就那个概念我就是在和大聊他
然后中间才会有一些对话是这样的第二个部分
然后第三个部分的话呢
就是你要学会去看数据
麻烦以后要看数据大家经常讨论的那些那种
经常聊那些那种感
感兴趣他会成为你的第二条视频
全体的来源
我看好多人这个动作是不做的
然后还有一个点我跟大家讲
就是我说要在评论的时候很容易会
会讨厌黑粉
甚至很能喜欢讨厌更新我告诉你我早就说特别喜欢黑粉
游期喜欢钢琴为什么
因为你说啥他要跟你干涉干涉上去
太好的
你知道吗
他在燃烧自己
为你的短视频
贡献热度就是我说我看到这种人我就我就
我就縮然体育又大心理
縮然体育的
这个还好体会一些的话
短视频不是
内容的输出和传播而是制造
对话
内容是中武藏
但是对话
可以让他
成为身体
所以各位好好想想你在过去
最棒的一次对话是什么时候
他是怎么发生的